apollinaire et j'ai appelé les
récitations de lui mais je pense que
vous avez compris
sous le pont mirabeau coule la seine ni
nos amours futile qu'il nous souvienne
la joie venait toujours après la peine
vienne la nuit 109 jay denney
je demeure les mains dans les mains
restons face à face tandis que sous le
pont du louvre aaron de nos bras passe d
été réservé mais le regard long de sylla
ça de l'air les jours s'en vont je
demeure l'amour s'en va comme c'est au
courant de l'amour sans fin comme la vie
est lente et comme l'espérance et
violente via les jours sans vous je
demeure
pas seul et jour et passent les semaines
étant passé ni les amoureux viennent
sous le pont mirabeau la fête viennent
la nuit sonne l'heure les jours s'en
vont je de marchica l'air
[Musique]